of them ensure that they're adhering to
the regulations around quarantine we ask
that if they have symptoms of measles
that includes her fever a cough or runny
nose red eyes or a rash their to call
their contact number and we will make
sure that they get services immediately
we quarantine people to avoid increasing
the numbers of cases of measles here in
LA County I want to give you an example
about how quickly you can have a huge
spread of measles if you have one
student at a university or college that
exposes a thousand people to measles
vaccine in the four days before they
know that they have measles and you
assume that about five percent of the
population may not be fully immunized or
protected from measles you now will have
between around fifty people who may in
fact be easily able to get sick from
measles because ninety percent of people
who are not immunized or haven't had
measles before when they're exposed to
measles are likely to get measles if now
you just assume thirty of those people
become infectious and they now expose
about five hundred people each and we
use the same ratios within a period of
weeks we could have around six hundred
people with measles here in LA County
that's why we're so serious about trying
to make sure that people who have been
in contact with someone who has measles
and are not immunized or cannot prove
that their immune stay away from other
people people who can be quarantine are
obviously those people who cannot
establish their immunity that's either
by showing us that they've had that
they're fully vaccinated and we require
proof of that vaccination or by showing
us that they've had a blood test that
establishes that they have immunity I
want to get to some numbers at UCLA
there were eight hundred and fifty three
students and seven faculty that were
exposed to the measles case early on we
were able to verify that 729 students
and two of the faculty members were in
fact either immunized or immune we
issued individual quarantine orders to
124 students and five faculty members of
those currently 45 students remain under
quarantine orders and one faculty member
all the rest have been cleared at Cal
State LA
there were 875 known students faculty
staff and visitors to the library and an
undetermined number of other folks from
whom we have no identification of those
we were able to initially issue 215
individual quarantine orders and those
were the people who worked in the North
library since then we also issued a
blanket order that actually asked
anybody who had been in the library on
April 11th between 11:00 and 3:00 p.m.
to self quarantine notify the health
services and establish that they in fact
were immune before they exposed
themselves to the public last night we
received another list from Cal State
they were able to go into the records of
folks that had used the computers at the
library between 11:00 and 3:00 and we've
since then been able
through Cal State to notify 660 people
these are both visitors students faculty
and staff that were in the library
between 11:00 and 3:00 that they might
have had an exposure to measles and they
need to report to health services to
verify their status so that they do not
need to be quarantined at this point in
time we've cleared 215 of the 660 folks
that were using the computers by just
matching their names to the state
registry and establishing that in fact
they're fully immunized of the 215
individual orders that we've issued 32
of those people have cleared so we have
another 183 people that are quarantined
with individual quarantine notices I
just wanted to make sure everyone had
numbers that's the best information I
want to say those numbers are good as of
this morning we clear cases as rapidly
as we can again I want to thank all of
the folks at both UCLA and Cal State LA
for their cooperation and helping to
really open up their health services and
clear as many folks as we can obviously
we know quarantine is a hardship we'd
like to avoid it wherever possible but
we do need that verification that folks
who are in contact with a case are in
fact either fully immunized or we have
an established blood test that shows
that they have immunity we're gonna just
quickly now open it up for questions how
much of this is due to the antibac
solute living in America oh yeah and
before I will answer it but I just want
to introduce the folks who are gonna
help answer questions so this is dr.
Silvia Prieto she is our regional health
officer she will also be available to do
interviews in Spanish afterwards and I'm
joined also as you know with our dr.
Davis our health officer and with dr.
Balter who is our director of acute
communicable
these control so sorry go ahead with
your question how much of this is due to
the anti-vaxxer I mean I think it's it
contributes in some way I mean if you're
not immunized then the risk of being
infected with measles and as mentioned 9
percent of those who are infected and
aren't immune you know will come down
with the DS disease and they will expose
others but I will say that you know that
is something that is just fact so no
matter what your belief is if you aren't
immunized that's going to be the risk so
I can't say 100 percent is related to an
tiebacks
those who aren't vaccinated are you know
can't get the disease and pose risk for
others I can't say that it's
specifically on all of that no we do
have to understand also that there are
certain folks that have medical reasons
that they cannot get you know immunized
and so those folks are not going to be
able to be protected and we have to
understand that everybody else who is
immunized actually protects them so they
will be at risk as well so I can't break
down and say these are the numbers of
folks that have medical exemptions and
these are the folks that just didn't
believe that they shouldn't get
immunized all right what I'm stating is
is that if you're not immunized that is
the risk no matter what the belief even
if you have a medical exemption and you
cannot be immunized people who are
unaware and transmitting useless and we
definitely know we have more people who
chose not to be immunized and now we
have an outbreak of measles and
obviously it's much easier to have an
outbreak when you have increased numbers
of people who aren't vaccinated right
these two students
say or not that person did they go to
Tecumseh but we're not going to disclose
that information there were some reports
that there were new numbers what you
said we just identified there are no new
numbers of people that were exposed
although again
I want to also note that we've asked
people to self-identify Cal State has
been great about doing sort of a major
blast so we might not have everybody on
our list though that went into that
library what we do have the new number
is we have 660 people's names that we
didn't have yesterday when we met and
when we talked with the press yesterday
as of last night we've been able to
identify an additional group of people
who we know were in the library that's
not all the people who were in the
library between 11:00 and 3:00 but we're
getting closer to being able to identify
folks who were there well the
universities in California the Cal State
and UCS do have a requirement of 2mm our
evidence of to MMR immunizations as part
of entry so in this instance dr. ferma
mentioned the California immunization
registry is one place to look and so a
lot of people you know can ask their
provider you know can you pull my
records if they don't have them we also
have to remember that when kids are
immunized there's often a written record
that is provided to parents and then
it's also an official record so we
really do rely on the health care system
in terms of either passing information
and proof of immunization to the family
or looking in the state registry
that you enroll it's just it's just a
new requirement for you this students
which means transfer students and like
the fresh fresh men and women students
to the incoming class and that was as of
2018 at UCLA so yes I mean we're we
probably got very good coverage for the
you know the the first-year students and
we probably don't have either as good
records or necessarily as good coverage
for some of the older students that are
on campus but anybody who transferred in
this last year or who's a new enrollee
there actually did have to show proof of
immunization which is one reason why
we're able to clear so many students so
quickly well some of them were exposed
they weren't they might not necessarily
have been you know as I said the number
at UCLA was upwards of over 800 we
actually only issued quarantine orders
there for about a hundred and
twenty-four students so we could rapidly
were able to clear because there were
records doctor what kinds of legal
mechanisms do you have to get people
vaccinated these circumstances because
our understanding is that there are some
jurisdictions where that is having
people can get fined cited is there any
kind of legal mechanism I mean we have
you know state regulations for school
entry in that I mean typically we're not
sort of saying okay in this situation
you're required to go get an
immunization and in these instances if
someone isn't immunized then they're we
want to make sure that they're not going
to expose others so in many of these
instances it really is about don't
you're not able to go out in order to
possibly infect others so and also in
this if you're exposed it's not after
the fact that you're going to get
immunized that's not going to
necessarily protect you if it's in a
short timeframe within 72 hours that may
give some protection but
but it's not one of those instances
where we would say everybody needs to go
out and be immunized in terms of an
emergency response I mean there are
again there's sort of the school
requirements you know for employment
requirements that are there that do
require folks to be immunized yeah I
mean we're not we're not forcing people
to get immunize but we are gonna
actually ask people to adhere to the
legal requirements of a quarantine order
so I think I think dr. Davis said this
well what we rely on is if you are not
immunized and we ask you now actually
require you now to stay away from other
people you have to stay away from other
people I mean it's it's you know if we
have to go to court because someone is
not following an order then we go
through the legal system and figure out
you know what will happen if they're not
following and I want to say as of right
now we don't have anybody that's not
adhering to the quarantine orders and is
telling us they're absolutely not going
to comply we've had great cooperation I
think people appreciate the fact that
there are very vulnerable people in our
communities that cannot get immunized
especially infants under six months and
you wouldn't want to inadvertently
expose somebody to a disease that can be
devastating for both infants pregnant
women people who have our immune
compromised and cannot be vaccinated so
I want to thank everybody who has
received their quarantine orders for
actually adhering to the quarantine and
we're very hopeful in this case that we
actually don't need to go to court or
pursue any legal action because we've
had a lot of cooperation
self-identifying we're gonna get a
report you know we're in contact every
day with the university this would
especially apply to the Cal State LA
campus because we don't know everybody
who was in the library Cal State has
reported to us that they have seen
dozens of people at their health
services I don't have the exact number
but I do want to commend them for doing
an amazing job on the outreach so they
blasted it out via both email and
notification all over the campus you
know I think the the truth is the vast
majority of people on the campus have
either been immunized or have immunity
so it's a very small number and I want
to emphasize this it's usually and in
this case we know for sure it's gonna be
a very small number of students and
faculty and staff that actually aren't
immunized and it's pretty easy if they
go to health services to have the folks
at Health Services help them verify
their status if you can't produce your
records very quickly you can get a blood
test and within about 24 to 48 hours
your status can be verified so you know
we we feel confident that most of the
people will in fact end up being able to
establish their immunity or that they're
fully immunized
so you said that there were 616 possible
that were in the library 215 were
cleared 183 oh I mean let me start over
and I'm sorry if I was confused there
are 875 known people who were at the
library between 11:00 and 3:00 on April
11th those are the people we know the
numbers 875 that students faculty staff
and visitors immediately we were able to
get a list of all of the faculty staff
and students who work at the library
that list led us to issue 215 individual
quarantine orders that's from that 875
number in addition the remaining it's a
should be 660 are the list that we
received late last night of students
faculty staff and visitors who used a
computer in the library during those
hours that's a new list but it makes up
that larger number of 875 of those 660
we've cleared 215 of them just by being
able to get their vaccination records
off of the state registry
the others are under a blanket
quarantine order right now and we'll
need to get clear to just outstanding
that don't know yes there are those are
the people we know we know the workers
and we know the people who use the
computers and we know the people who
checked out books very small number if
you went to that library between 11:00
and 3:00 and you did none of those
activities you're not a worker you
didn't check out a book and you didn't
log onto the computer we don't know who
you are you need to self-identify
but thanks for making making that clear
you know a Don self identification
usually you know people want to find out
their own risk and so self
identification allows you to talk to a
health care provider figure out you know
what's going on or talk to us as public
health figure out what's going on figure
out how you figure out whether or not
you're at risk or not and at the same
time many people want to know am I going
to put my family members at risk and so
really you know we're it's really about
providing information you know based on
their situation
I don't think we're frustrated I mean I
think it's a challenge and it's not just
a challenge for Public Health it's also
a challenge for providers a lot of
people a lot of you know doctors that
are practicing now that are younger
doctors they've never seen a case of
measles so they're also you know need to
do a fair amount of learning you know to
recognize the rash to understand the
symptoms to set up their clinics to
really minimize exposures to other folks
but yeah I mean it's a different time we
do have these outbreaks I want to say
it's fortunate that we actually prepare
and practice for outbreaks as a local
public health department we have plans
that we put into action so it's not like
we're trying to invent what we're going
to do when we see an outbreak because
for some communicable diseases we
actually have vaccinations that help
people really reduce their risk but
there are others where we don't and so
you know we're prepared for the worst
scenarios as well which you were
describing earlier though he's what they
call her the immunity right so that's
how the outbreaks occur is this a
breakdown of herd immunity yeah I mean
the more people that are protected the
less likely of disease transmission
which is right it's really important
that those who could get immunized get
immunized in order to protect especially
those who cannot be immunized and so
that's the herd I mean it's it's what
you'd see with families with newborns
you know when we talk about the rest of
the family getting the influenza
immunization in order to protect that
infant it's the same concept but for the
larger community
is great basically on your confidence
level is right now with where the
stopper it is and whether it's under
control or you guys thought you sends
you're trying to yeah we're we'd I mean
we cannot say definitively I've an wish
we could answer you I can say we're
doing everything we can we have a lot of
cooperation from the communities at both
of these universities I also want to
remind everyone although we've been
focused a lot on the universities
because these are settings where people
are in very close contact with each
other we also do have other cases in the
community we continue to be you know a
port and international destination
there's outbreaks all across the world
and in other parts of the United States
so even if we managed to find every
single contact here managed to isolate
everyone who came in contact and wasn't
immunized
we still have enormous risk here in LA
County as do so many other communities
because there are outbreaks everywhere
and because there's a lot of measles
that's around them in real terms for the
rest of us that means what they avoid
intimate contact or close contact like
this get immunized that's what it really
means it means if you want to protect
yourself and you want to protect others
we have in this case a really good
vaccine 97% effective if you have two
doses 97% that's a lot of protection
if you have the one you can talk with
your provider about whether you'd be a
good candidate for the second dose
obviously if you're doing a lot of
international travel you may want to
think about talking with your provider
about getting that second dose but I do
want to say there is a way for you to
protect yourself and that is to be fully
immunized do you recommend that people
just go people that are 44 above perhaps
go and just get another immunization or
get the blood test to find out that you
so there's certainly rapport it's very
important that they have two doses and
those would be definitely international
travelers especially right now as dr.
Ferrer said there is a lot of measles in
the world um health care workers anybody
who works in a hospital
anyone who's caring for someone who's at
risk for serious illness such as an
infant someone who's immune compromised
you cannot get the vaccine if you are
pregnant but if you're a woman who knows
you might be planning to get pregnant
you can get the vaccine as long as you
wait 28 days before you try to get
pregnant so those are people who we
would absolutely emphasize should get
two doses of vaccine for other people
what we're saying is when you visit your
provider you should ask your provider do
I have documentation of measles vaccine
if not should I get another dose should
I be tested if you only had one dose and
it is true that there are many adults
who only had one dose it is not
unreasonable to go ahead and get a
second dose now and maintain that
documentation so you have it if you are
exposed anybody who is exposed to a case
of measles and doesn't have that
documentation may be subject to
quarantine and also if you haven't if
you truly are onion eyes door under
immunized you may be at risk for measles
as people have pointed out so it's not
it's not the level of emergency where
everybody has to go to their doctor but
it's definitely something where you
should talk to your doctor and certain
people especially
people who are traveling internationally
should get the vaccine even infants if
they're traveling internationally needs
to tell them the parents need to tell
the providers and talk to them about
what they can do some of the cases have
been hospitalized and some have not I
don't think we're gonna give out that
information today I want to go back to
that question about outbreak so in
reality the outbreak is among four cases
confirmed cases that are linked the
reason this has become big news is
because two of those contacts to those
cases had contact with over 1,700 folks
between them that could have been at
risk and that's what we've been
assessing so it's not as if and we do
have you know a number of cases five
cases that have traveled through anyway
so measles is out there but we don't
have widespread you know documented
cases and those people infecting others
in this particular instance we have four
cases that are linked the rest of them
are not linked at all I'm gonna just
pause and see if there's anybody on the
phone that had a question question
please press star then 1 on your
telephone keypad and we first turn to
the line of Michelle
are safe and effective but can you
characterize the risk of a person not
being vaccinated as opposed to being
maybe getting harm from Rebecca yes
measles can be a very serious illness
and because luckily as others have said
in the modern era we haven't seen a lot
of measles people forget that one to two
out of every thousand people who get
measles will die of measles
either from respiratory complications
are getting a brain infection called
encephalitis and another one in a
thousand will become brain damage from
encephalitis so these are very very
serious consequences and around the
world we are beginning to see that again
there are the vaccine has been
repeatedly studied and is safe and
effective you know everything can have
some risk but the risk of measles vastly
outweighs the risk of the vaccine and
that is why in public health we urge
people to get measles vaccine it's the
best way to prevent measles and again
measles itself can be very very serious
is there another question on the phone
we have five we have five cases four are
linked to each other one is not we have
five cases in LA County residents five
additional cases we've been notified of
people who have passed through la
International Airport
vacations you know do you know how many
of those that's in people who were
overseas
one or two of faculty nobody nobody of
the five resident cases receive two
doses of the vaccine yes one one one
case received one dose of the vaccine so
as we said earlier if you receive only
one dose rather than two you can still
get measles one dose is 93 percent
effective two doses is 97 so one is good
two is better you're let the illness is
likely to be less severe if you've had
at least one dose of vaccine but it's
better to have two doses of vaccine you
know if you can which is why we're
recommending that people ask their
providers in addition just a reminder if
you're traveling internationally your
risk is much much higher right now and
so if you believe you've only had one
dose or you are unsure you need to make
sure that you have two doses of vaccine
and that was also recently recommended
by CV page stressing that if you are an
international traveler two doses is
better for you given the number of cases
of measles in other countries no as far
as we know we have nobody who's reported
illness I want to remind folks that your
infectious four days before you get a
rash and many times you have students
you think you're fine and then you get
sick but you've been infected by
infectious for a few days before you've
showed any signs of being sick
mind boggling the numbers of people
who've been bein one-time issue require
individual pointy nose at each campus at
UCLA at UCLA we issued quarantine orders
for a total of 129 people five faculty
124 students at Cal State LA we issued
215 individual quarantine orders and
then we have another blanket quarantine
order for anybody who was in the library
between 11:00 and 3:00 we know now that
there are six hundred and sixty people
whose names we have who were in the
library
the university has sent them a copy of
that blanket order so that they know
that they're under a quarantine order
until they establish their immunity okay
but the numbers are very large we agree
exactly but they're not in they don't
have an individual order they they're
covered by a blanket order that covers
anybody who was in that library during
that period 215 those are people who
work there okay thank you thank you
I mean any other questions in the room
people that cannot get vaccinated
your advice to them is just they should
people do something same question if
they're that's a good question
well for people who are not vaccinated
if they know they're exposed to come
forward quickly they can sometimes
receive something called immune globulin
which can protect them from getting the
illness if if they can come forward
within six days of being exposed so it
is to be aware it's also to encourage
the people they know and love and
interact with to get vaccinated because
that is what protects everyone in the
community that measles vaccine will
protect you yourself but it will also
protect your loved ones you know and I'd
use this as an opportunity to also sort
of plug you know good sick leave
policies at employed that employers have
so that people who are sick don't come
to work people who have children who are
sick are able to stay home and take care
of their children you know part of what
really protects people who can't get
immunized is that they're not also
exposed to people who are sick and feel
like they have no options when they are
sick so you know it's in this case it's
about telling people to please get
immunized but in other cases these are
the very same people who are also
vulnerable for other infectious diseases
and we would encourage everyone when
you're sick you need to stay home and
seek care if you're very sick other
questions in the room I'll go back to
the phone where's anybody else who had
queued up on the phone yes the orders
are very specific so yes the quarantine
orders make it very clear that you can't
use public transportation thank you very
much
we have a question for the line dandy
Lamarck with dns please go ahead no it
it went later than that I want to say
that it's in April 7th I think the last
exposure there was probably April 7th
but we're gonna just check as we don't
have that date in front of us yes yes
[Music]
yeah it's a it's a it's a great question
um you know I think one thing we pointed
out is you're exposed before a person
becomes sick a person becomes sick and
doesn't always go in to see their
provider immediately so there's and then
once they see their provider we've
actually had cases here where the
provider has not diagnosed it
immediately then when it does need to
get diagnosed there needs to be lab
testing that verifies that diagnosis and
then we need to find all the contacts so
you know we we try our best to go as
quickly as possible but you can see all
along that there are places where there
are going to be delays and where people
are gonna have had an exposure before we
can let them know that they were in
contact with a person that has a
confirmed case of measles
well we we have a very good list at the
University of California and we have
very good tracking from that student
about exactly where they were and they
were generally in spaces where we could
identify the contacts in that space but
your apps and we could go back on the
campuses to all the days they had been
on the campus during their infectious
period but you're absolutely right which
is why we appreciate all the messaging
you're doing there are probably many
people with both of these cases and
certainly with some of our other cases
that have had an exposure and we don't
know their name and that's why we ask
people to pay particular attention to
where they were when we issue a broad
notice that says if you were at the
library during this time please
self-identify we can do that where we
know somebody's been in a large public
space but we also try to tell people
find out your immunization status get
immunized if you can and if you have any
signs or symptoms and you're feeling ill
you need to talk to your provider
there's measles in our area and in our
communities and the exposures were on
April 2nd 4th and 9th was the last
exposure
I know I doubt that I mean I think what
happens is again you know the
universities just started requiring
verification for their incoming class so
for those students who are new to that
university just enrolled in this last
year they've had to already show that
verification so the university has
copies of that I think for the rest of
us we're not walking around with our
immunization records and in this case it
took some time for some of those
students to actually get to their
parents or for their parents to get to
the pediatricians and actually secure
the proof that they had been immunized
you know I want to remind you know
everyone that the other route that folks
are taking is to get a blood test to
establish your immunity so there are
many of us who will never be able to get
those immunization records particularly
those of us who are older and we will
have to rely perhaps on having a test to
establish that is correct and that is as
of this morning so those numbers as I
can I can give you a little bit of a
better number it's a hundred and
eighty-three people are under quarantine
who received an individual order we
started with 215 people received an
individual quarantine order that's a
quarantine order that comes with your
name attached to it of those we have we
have cleared about 32 and we have a
hundred and eighty-three people with
individual quarantine orders that remain
in effect as of this morning for the 660
folks that we identified last night
would that mean that the university
identified last night and sent them a
copy of the blanket order this is the
order that covers everybody who goes in
and out of that library not an
individual order but of those 660 we
have cleared 215 so there are 445 folks
on that list of 660 that remain under
that blanket quarantine order who we
have there
and then there is an unknown group of
folks who are under that blanket
quarantine order whose name we don't
know and whose numbers we don't have
those folks have been asked to
self-report at health services does that
help and are subject to that blanket
quarantine order but we don't know who
they are so we can't tell you that
number we the two initial cases who were
sick with measles one was a case at UCLA
and one was a case that was at Cal State
that was what that comment was in
reference to
you know I don't know that we have an
exact threshold anytime we have an a
case we try to identify both the number
of cases that we have that are confirmed
and also think through the number of
contacts etc and really try to figure
out what is they act what are the
actions that need to be taken in order
to protect the broader community as well
as their contacts that is a very unique
situation where they are there are
significantly higher numbers of cases
but we are not in that situation at this
moment and you know I want to emphasize
particularly on the campuses we have
very high rates of immunization so it's
a very different situation because we
actually have known high rates of
immunization